afghanistan's acting prime minister says
officials who fled are free to safely
return and play a role in the taliban's
interim government
hassan akun spoke to al jazeera a day
after veteran taliban figures were named
in top posts he again promised amnesty
for those who worked in the former
government or with foreign forces
we have suffered huge losses in money
and lives for this historical moment in
the history of afghanistan
the stage of bloodshed killing and
contempt for people in afghanistan has
ended and we have paid dearly for this
the officials of the taliban movement
are facing a great responsibility and
test
i ask god to guide them all
but the movement is disciplined and
controls its gunmen
and we have not harmed anyone because of
their previous actions
therefore i assure the islamic nation
especially the afghan people that we
want all the good the causes for success
and welfare and we seek to establish an
islamic system
i ask everyone to participate with us in
this blessed project